welcome to
lecture 11 of cs229 um the plan today is
to
wrap up deep learning um and we we left
off at the end of back propagation
last lecture and we probably the last
part was probably a little bit hurried
so we're going to
cover it again just to make sure you all
understood it
properly and then once we wrap up
deep learning we're going to the goal is
to
cover regularization today and before we
start regularization
we will give a fairly informal
introduction to bias variance and um
so just enough so that we can kind of
cover regularization in a meaningful way
and we'll go deeper into
bias and variance against on on the
friday lecture
so to recap where we left off
last lecture was ah we
we discussed neural networks a neural
network is basically
a composition of multiple layers of
computation
where each layer you can think of them
as a vector of
neurons and each neuron um
which which is represented as a circle
in each of these
layers is takes as input the entire
previous the output of the neurons from
the previous layer
perform some kind of a computation and
the output of this neuron becomes the
input for
the neurons of the next layer right so
networks are structured in this
compositional way where the output of
one function becomes the input to the
next function and
the output of that function becomes the
input to the next function and so on
and in the case of
binary classification where the the goal
of this
network which is also called a neural
network is to perform classification
the last layer which is also called the
output layer
the output layer ah will have just one
neuron
and the output of this neuron is
considered the output of the network
right and we take the output of this
network
and the output the value of the output
of the network depends on
the on the parameter value within the
network and also what
input we fed into the network right so
the input of the network gets translated
to the output of the network
and corresponding to the input there is
a correct answer
y i right we take y i and the prediction
y y hat i and construct a loss
and the goal is to minimize the
loss for every x i y i pair and the way
we go about doing that is through
gradient descent right and gradient
descent we have seen gradient descent
for linear models before
where the the idea is to take
the the gradient or the derivative of
the
loss with respect to parameters not with
respect to the input
we take the the gradient of the loss
with respect to the parameters
and update the parameters to take a
small step in the direction of the
negative of the gradient
right and we are going to do the same
thing with the neural network
and the big challenge with the neural
network or rather the only challenge is
not really a big challenge
is how are we going to compute the
gradients of
all the parameters at the same time
simultaneously
the gradient of the loss with respect to
all the parameters simultaneously right
so the
the and that's where the back
propagation algorithm comes into picture
and back propagation is essentially just
the chain rule
so if you're familiar with chain rule
then back propagation will will seem
very natural there's no magic in back
propagation it's just the chain rule
um so the same network um
so this is the network view and this is
the computation graph view of the same
network
and before we go into the computation
graph you let's remind ourselves
if we have a function f that takes an
input in rn
and outputs a vector in r m
so vector input vector output kind of a
function
now the the derivative of the output of
that function with respect to its input
will be a matrix a matrix
which which has as many number of rows
as the number of outputs
and as many number of rows as many
number of columns as the number of
inputs and this is called the jacobian
of the function this question yeah so
this might be a very basic question
every time we uh learned a new algorithm
and we computed the gradient because we
wanted
yeah so so so the question is uh when we
covered
all the gradient ascent and descent
techniques maximum likelihood techniques
uh we are seeing methods where we take
the gradient of the loss with respect to
parameters and take a small step
and perform gradient ascent or descent
why not do
why not take the gradient and set it
equal to zero and solve for the
parameters directly like how we did with
uh the maximum ah with respect to linear
regression right
and um the answer for that is you can do
that whenever it's possible
right so whenever possible whenever you
can take a gradient set it equal to 0
and solve for the right
parameter values absolutely do that
however
for a lot of models such as even
including logistic regression
there is no analytical solution you can
you can take the gradient set it equal
to zero and try to solve what the
parameter values
you just won't get a closed form
solution
and that's the only reason and if it is
possible you can absolutely do it
and the other reason is that um in cases
when your
loss function is not convex there may be
lots of
local minimums and when you set
a gradient equal to zero in theory you
could land you know in in
any of the local minimas or you could
even land at a local maxima if your loss
function has you know local maximas so
just setting the gradient equal to zero
just takes you to a stationary point
whereas with gradient descent we can end
up in local minimas but it's you know
at least you stay away from local
[Music]
maximus
so um the question is how how um
how frequently do we um
why not numerically calculate what value
of the gradient
or what value of the parameters will set
the gradient equal to zero and gradient
ascent is
the algorithm you would use to perform
that numerically
okay um right so
uh this is the the
jacobian where if you have a vector
valued output and a vector valued input
the derivative of the output with
respect to input is going to be a matrix
a matrix whose number of rows equals the
number of
elements in the output vector and the
number of columns equals the number of
elements in the input vector
right and now we are going to use uh
we're going to see how the jacobian can
be used here because
we are now going to start thinking of
this network
as these blobs of computation right
every blob over here
which is which is uh you know not a
rectangle you can think of it as some
function
that takes some inputs so incoming
arrows into this blob
are the are the inputs to the function
and outgoing arrows are
the outputs of the function so for
example consider this
this function f which has output
which we call as a1 and input as as z1
so the derivative of this function which
takes
whose output is some vector input to
some vector
is going to be a matrix the the
derivative of this function is going to
be a matrix
right and the the derivative of a with
respect to the vector a with respect to
z
is therefore the jacobian of of of this
function
right and with this computation view
basically we have represented the same
network what happens in this networks
in this network as a computation graph
so we take the input
the input goes into the first function
whose functions are
the input itself and two parameters so
all the blue blocks are the parameters
with respect to which we want to perform
gradient or central descent and
the first layer takes takes
the the input example two parameters
computes
z equals w x plus b and we call that z
and after that it applies a
non-linearity it takes
the non-linearity is applied in an
element-wise fashion
and we get a non-linear output we which
we call it as
a right and this entire
set of operations we call it as one
layer so this
makes up a layer right and then we take
the output of this layer
and run it through this this function
which is again
you know w two a plus b and we get
a vector z and from z we apply another
function
which gives us a vector a so we are kind
of hopping from
vector to vector to vector to vector
right
and some there are some function that
transforms one vector to another and
another function that transforms this
vector to another and so on
and this can go on for you know many
number of layers
you know any number of layers and
in general we we you know um with such
networks we
we generally use the term capital l to
denote the number of layers
so this this story repeats all the way
till we get we come to a
l minus one so the l minus one
layer we take the output of the l minus
one layer
and now because we are trying to do
binary classification our output needs
to be scalar valued
right and and so the the uh
the functions uh this function will have
a scalar output
so take this this vector as the input
dot it with this w so w w a will now be
a scalar
we add another scalar so we get a scalar
and then apply a non-linearity again
and we get y hat so this is the output
of the network
right and once we have the output of the
network we take
the y i corresponding to the x i
to compute a loss so in case of binary
classification the loss is
y log y hat plus 1 minus y log 1 minus y
hat we take the negative of that
for the loss and that's our loss
now the goal is to perform gradient
descent we need to take the derivative
of the loss with respect to b
l the loss with respect to w l
the derivative of the loss with respect
to b2
and w2 and b1 and w1 and so on right
and once we calculate those
those uh gradients or derivatives we can
perform gradient descent
right so that's that's the
that's the setting in which you know
backdrop comes into picture
and if you remember the chain rule of
calculus
when we need to compute the gradient of
say
the loss a scalar with respect to
some element let's call it
w 2 i j so this is a matrix and let us
you know think of this as the i j th
element of
of that matrix if we want to
calculate ah let me use a different
color
agent of loss
with respect to say w
two i j
and the chain rule of calculus tells us
that
we because all these composition
all these functions are compositions
where the output of one
becomes the input of the other and so on
we can
take the local derivatives of each of
these and multiply them up
right that's basically the chain rule of
multivariate chain rule of calculus
and the the reason why the multivariate
chain rule of calculus is different from
the regular you know chain rule of
calculus
is because the intermediate values can
be vectors right
so here l is a scalar w i j
is a scalar right but the intermediate
values are all vectors
which is why we use the multivariate
chain rule of calculus
and what does this come out to so first
let us calculate
all the all the intermediate pieces and
then we'll just join them together
right so first
so so the so the picture in mind uh you
want to have is you're jumping from you
know boxes to boxes
in our computation graph so we take the
derivatives also
you know boxes to boxes right so
first we start from the very end the
loss with respect to a2
right so this we're going to call this
loss with respect to
a2 scalar scalar what's going to be the
dimension of this
scalar right so this is going to give us
the gradient of the loss with respect to
a2
and then a2 with respect to z
loss with respect to z
so this was a scalar this is a scalar
what's the derivative going to be
scalar again very good
be with respect to a
l yeah this is you're you're right
that's not a two you're right thank you
thank you
a l right and now
from z we need to take
what's the derivative of zl with respect
to bl
what what dimension is going to be this
is scalar this is a scalar and the
z l with respect to partial of
bl what's the dimension of this scale r
very good
and now what's the derivative of of zl
with respect to wl this is a scalar and
this is a vector
right so this is going to be according
to
the jacobian view m which is the output
is a scalar
and n which is w is the is a vector
so it's going to be a row vector because
we have one output
and you know some number of inputs right
so this this
is going to be
a row vector
partial of z
l over partial of
wl
right and now so that was one branch
and we're going to continue down the you
know main trunk of the network so at
each layer we're going to branch off
into
you know the parameters but we're going
to continue down the trunk of the
network to reach to get to the
previous layers parameters right so from
z to a so z is
a scalar a is a vector
so the derivative is going to be
it's going to be a vector again uh but
it's still going to be a row vector
so in this case we i've just you know
written then we'll say but you know
scalar output vector input the jacobian
is going to be a row vector
right follow this convention scalar
output vector input it is going to be a
row
think of it as a row vector so
this will be
del z l with respect to
delta a l minus 1
this will be
a row vector
all right and now and so on ah
you know we go from layer to layer and
let's say we reach here
from whatever the next layer was and
from here to here
vector valued output vector valued input
so the jacobian is going to be a matrix
exactly
so here we this will be
a matrix
a two this is two
over z
two
right and similarly from from here to
here
uh the derivative of z with respect to b
b2 so this is a vector this is a vector
so the jacobian will be a
matrix ah however
before at the last layer before we uh
calculate the the uh
the derivatives as a matrix here we are
going to make use of the fact
that we want to calculate
it with respect to each of the elements
of the matrix or
or this vector and the reason why we
want to
calculate the the derivative of the z
vector with respect to each of the
elements separately
is purely for computation reasons right
you could have
followed the same approach and
calculated the jacobian over here
and taken the derivative of the vector
with respect to a matrix and you would
have gotten something in three
dimensions
and mathematically that's perfectly fine
but computationally that is going to be
very inefficient
right so for computation purposes we're
going to take the derivative
of each cell in this grid or each cell
in this vector separately with respect
to
the z vector right and so the goal is to
calculate it with respect to w
i j you want to start from a scalar
end with a scalar and take the
derivative which is going to give us a
scalar
that's that's that's the idea here so uh
let's see how that works out
so here we want to take
the consider say the ijth element
and from z
and what is the dimension going to be
here so z is a
z is a vector and this is a scalar so
the derivative will be a
row vector or column vector
so the number of outputs is
the number of rows so here the number of
outputs
is multiple so the number of rows in
that matrix is going to be multiple
but the number of columns in the matrix
is the number of inputs we have just as
a scalar so this will be a column vector
right
so this is del z
2 del
w 2 i j
all right now this recipe can be applied
so
we have pretty much so we are missing
this one more all right
so uh that z to a
is again going to be a so this is vector
output vector input so this is also
going to be a
matrix jacobian matrix
right now a few few observations that we
want to make the first is that
what we do in each layer repeats in
every layer
right so once we figure out what each of
these
values are we can just repeat them at
every layer
because each layer is just a repetition
just the number of dimensions will be
different
but the math that we use to calculate
the
ijth element is going to be the same at
each layer
right and we are essentially kind of
toggling between
z to a a to z z to a a to z z to a
a to c and so on until we come to the l
minus 1 layers a
and then we have you know something
different
right so we have
you know something that's non-repetitive
at the last layer
followed by something that repeats
alternatively
l number of times or l minus 1 number of
times all the way until we reach the
input
right so its sufficient to see
how this pattern works for one example
and once we do that
it is very easy to just repeat the same
recipe to any given
any given um parameter in the network
yes question
with respect to each element yes that's
right so yeah so the question is
um um are we going to take the uh
derivative with respect to each element
in w
uh for the uh yes that's that is
uh what we will do uh the the reason is
because it's computationally efficient
you can take
the derivative of with respect to the
entire matrix directly
uh and that will the the intermediate
step to go from
a matrix to a vector will give you
something in three dimensions
and it turns out that you know in that
entire three dimension volume most of it
you know
pretty much everything will be just
zeros except a small fraction of them
will be non-zeros
which is is uh
which is the same value we will get if
we start from you know take the
cell point of view so think of it as one
parameter scalar parameter to scalar
loss
with a whole bunch of jacobians in the
middle um
with respect to each so lets lets lets
work out
one example and maybe that will answer
your question
so so what we are going to do now is try
to calculate
the gradient of the loss l
scalar with respect to w i j and we'll
see what happens for all the
ah you know with the layers in between
so this we are going to
compose it as
loss with respect to
a l times
loss respect to z
l times
loss with respect to
a l minus 1
times right
i am just going to take it down
l minus 1 times loss
with respect to z
l minus 1 and
can i use a black one the only black pen
here is
all right it's writing now all right let
me use the black one
um so okay i'm just going to
start all over again
right so just to keep this in view uh
i'm not going to push it all the way up
so the
derivative of the loss with respect to
w 2 i j
is equal to now using the chain rule we
break it up into components
loss with respect to
a l times
derivative of the loss with respect to
z l times
of the loss with respect to a
l minus one times
two z l minus 1
and so on until we reach
let's continue from here until
derivative
of a 2
times derivative of z
2 times derivative of
z 2 times derivative of
w 2 i j
right so this is just the chain rule
what we a l l uh
derivative of l with respect to a was a
scalar
right so this is 1 cross 1
right l with respect to z
sorry this should have been a l oops
sorry sorry about that so
this will be a l and this will be
z l this will be a
l minus 1 c l minus 1 and so on
right so l 2 lost to a l
is 1 1 b 1 cross 1 lost to z l
a l to z l was again 1 cross 1
right
a l to z l was one cross one and then
z l to a l minus one was a
one cross so uh for the sake of
simplicity let's assume
that all the all the
vectors are have dimension m right
so i'm just going to call this 1 cross
m right and a l minus 1 to z l minus 1
a l minus 1 to z l minus 1 was just like
this was again m by m
right and so on until a two to z
two a two to z two was again
m by m and z
z two two w two i j
was m cross one
exactly this is m cross one
and it so happens that if we have
each at each layer if we have a
different dimension
then this would have been say m l minus
and this would be m l minus 1 till m l
minus 2.
you know but you know there's still
going to be jacobians of of
you know of matrices right and now we
can see that
l uh the uh the derivative of loss with
respect to w i j
this must be one one one cross one with
a scalar output scalar input
right but in the in the middle we have
all these matrices
um and vectors and and what not and what
we will see
is that when you start multiplying them
out so
this together
is 1 cross 1 and this and this together
is 1 cross m l minus 1
and this together
is 1 cross l minus 1 and l minus 1
you know they they go out so this will
be 1 cross
m l minus 2 and so on until you reach
here
right and this will be 1 cross m
and this is times m cross 1 will give us
1 cross 1
right so this and this long daisy chain
of jacobians
will always will always always when you
multiply them out condense into a scalar
right and if it doesn't there's a bug in
your mat somewhere because it always
will condense to a scalar
because it's the scalar loss with
respect to scalar parameter
and all of these need to just you know
collapse into a scalar
right and what we see here now is
we did this experiment for um you know
in in terms of you know writing them out
as just
these partials we can simplify
this a little further so we can we can
uh you know make two observations here
now in place of w two
what if we wanted to calculate
loss with respect to
w i j from 1
right we did it for layer up to layer 2
until w 2 what if we wanted to do it
till layer one
all right
exactly so what we do is to calculate
the
uh the derivative of loss with respect
to w one i j
everything we did till z two was the
same
at z two we branched off instead for w
one we continue down the trunk
right we take this jacobian and this
jacobian
and we end up with z1 and from z1 we
again branch off just the way we did it
here
right in order to to compute the
derivative of
w1ij with respect to l
we reused everything until z2
and you know this this is you know quite
a long list
it could be possibly a pretty long list
of of computation
and then we just ignore what we did in
the in in you know that's specific to
that branch of that layer
and then get two more jacobians and
branch off into this layer
right that's how we reuse computation if
we were to perform
if you were to calculate the the loss
with respect to w i j and then
you know ignore it forget it and then
start over all the way again
with respect to w two i j we would be
recomputing all these intermediate
jacobians a whole number of times
right and gradient uh back propagation
is an algorithm
that tells you what is the most you know
optimal or efficient way to compute
these
compute these gradients by reusing the
intermediate computation as much as
possible
so where were we
so ah if if we wanted to calculate
with respect to w 1j
then this would be now am going to call
this
l with respect to
e z 2
times z 2
and e2 times
of a1
a1 to z2 times delta
a1 times del z 1
times del z 1
times del w
i j of 1
right so this whole thing
is
right all these got reused
over here ah you know we would have
computed this
you know just save that value and plug
it in here
and just compute these extra jacobians
and derivatives
right so this will still be one
cross m this would be m cross
m m cross m m
cross 1 right and you combine these
you get 1 cross 1 and this is also 1
cross 1
this question
yeah so the
so the derivative of the final loss with
respect to w
one i j w 1 i j
will be the same until
you know uh we're going to reuse
everything we use for w 2 i j until z 2
layer
right and and then we branched off for w
2 i j
instead we will continue by calculating
two more jacobians
and branch off towards w one i j right
so everything until z two
is written here and the the the thing
highlighted in the blue
blue square is this blue square they are
the same
so we're going to just reuse everything
we did until here
just discard the last component which
was in the branch
right and now this part you know the the
reused part
and these two extra jacobians is is now
like the new trunk the new we extend
down the trunk and
and the last part is the branch that's
specific to the layer one
okay good question yes question you said
that you use
d l over d c so you have
uh d l over d w right
what's dl over so dl over dw is
what is what we calculated for
the second layer and in order to
calculate it you know this was an
intermediate
result in the computation right and
we're going to reuse this
intermediate computation for performing
ah for calculating uh loss of l with
respect to w
uh w1 right so yeah that's that's
important we are not using
the gradient of the gradient of
loss with respect to w2 to calculate the
gradient of loss with respect to w1
right because this branch what happens
here has no bearing on
the loss with respect to w1 right you're
only going to use
um you know we only going to use the
parts until z2
and then calculate the rest and we're
going to just discard
uh discard everything in this branch
that's specific to w2
we're going to discard it for
calculating the derivative with respect
to w1
any any questions on this before we see
how each of the individual components
look
right so let
us look at this again now ah there are
lots of lots of
you know intermediate jacobians here one
observation that we can do
is
right until here everything to the right
of the last l minus 1
output this should be familiar to you
it may not look familiar but you have
seen this before this is just logistic
regression
right if this was your x assume you are
just feeding your x's
you know the inputs at this layer what
you have here is logistic regression
so the the way to think of this as a
logistic regression is
now combine these into a theta vector
right and extend this by adding a 1
as the intercept term and you do theta
transpose x you get a scalar
take it through the sigmoid function you
get your y hat
and you take your y and y hat and
compute the log likelihood right
so everything to the right of this you
know blue line over here
is logistic regression there is no
difference whatsoever
the difference is only notational
computationally this is just logistic
regression
after the last layer right so you know
this is you think of this as your theta
vector
like this like theta naught and theta
one till theta d and this is um
like your x x i and you know assume
there is an extra
intercept term take the dot product
between theta and x you get theta
transpose x
take it through sigmoid you get your y
hat this question
so i i've just uh drawn this as a row
vector here
uh you know but think of this as you
know
think of this as you know just some
vector you know don't worry too much of
whether there is a row vector or column
matrix it's just some vector
so we take the the inner product between
or the dot product between this vector
and this vector yeah
so the output is a scalar yeah otherwise
so if this was a vector
if this was a matrix yeah okay so if
this was a matrix and this was
a vector then the output would also be a
vector
why is it a row vector here is it
because you want a scalar
if so yeah because we want we want a
scalar here exactly
because we are doing binary
classification we want uh y hat in fact
uh if you want to do multi-class
classification with a neural network
then this would
be a matrix and you would have one
uh one one element per class and you
would have a soft max instead of the
sigmoid
right so so think of everything to the
right of
this line to be a glm if you're doing
classification it is logistic regression
if you're doing regression then this is
this is linear regression if you're
doing
you know counts then this is poisson
regression so
a glm you know you can attach a glm at
the
at a l minus one right
so now in order to compute
these
in order to compute these individual
parts
we're going to make the observation that
d l to d a
l minus 1. so
all the way till here this whole thing
is basically what we saw in case of
logistic regression so this is going to
be y minus
so in case of logistic regression it was
y minus h theta of
x times x i
so the the equivalent thing ah
that we're going to have here will be y
i minus a
l
times
minus a l times a l minus one
does that make sense so everything until
here is going to is going to be just
and now
so if you if you think of
a l minus 1 as as like the input of
logistic regression
oh wait a second i think flipped it here
so this would not be a l minus 1 this
would be wl
so in logistic regression you had
a theta vector and an x vector right and
the derivative of the loss with respect
to theta
had x in it but x and theta are
symmetric so the derivative of
loss with respect to x would have been y
minus h theta of
x times theta
right so here we are trying to take the
derivative with respect to
so
yeah so in in case of logistic
regression
l of l with respect to del of
theta was y minus h
theta of x times
x l with respect to
x will be y minus h
theta of x times theta because x and
theta
are symmetric here
right so this whole thing over here
evaluates to just
right so you see that you see the parts
that are getting used here right
so pretend this was x pretend this was
theta
of logistic regression and calculate the
loss with respect to
uh you know this theta and
you get this so uh get this
right and in the notes we have you know
worked out the details of this you can
see the step by step of how you get this
for
for the initial part right and then we
you know
so once we once we compute this
the rest over here are the repeating
patterns in our chain of jacobians
right so this was the part that's
specific to the the end of the network
which is like a logistic regression or
you know any other glm
what what what happens further
are basically a to z z to a a to z z to
a the repeating pattern per layer yes
question
so why the weight is
over here yeah yeah so
in case of logistic regression um see
the uh kind of
similarity with logistic regression if
you're taking the derivative of the loss
with respect to theta you get an x if
you're taking
of the loss with respect to x you get a
theta so similarly
if you're taking the derivative of of
the loss with respect to a
you'll have the w show up here and if
you're taking uh the derivative of the
loss with respect to w
and a will show up here right
right so in this in this long
chain we have you know uh condensed the
first three
and by observing that this is
essentially just logistic regression
and we know the the gradient for
logistic regression
and this is the one cross m l minus one
so this is our row vector
does it make sense all the way until
here
is this and this is a row vector so this
is a scalar this is
a vector so this is a row vector now
until here now we've got the row vector
so much
and and now we're going to calculate
these these matrices
right and the matrices are are again
pretty straightforward
so d
z by d a so let's let's uh let
so let's try this
del a of l minus 1
del
z of l minus 1.
so how do we go from z to a
we perform an element wise non-linearity
right so in this matrix
where the the output corresponds to the
a's
and the input corresponds to the zs
this will be a square matrix because you
know we are just performing an element
wise multiplication
and because we are doing an element wise
multiplication the effect of
the ith element of z is
has no effect on the jth element of a if
i and j are different
right because this is the element wise
so this will be a diagonal matrix the
jacobian is going to be a diagonal
matrix
because it is an element wise operation
there is no interaction between
a i and zj if i and j are not the same
and so here this will just end up being
g
prime g prime
g prime
yeah so a i equals
g of z i
it's an element wise operation so the
jacobian of the a
vector with respect to the z vector will
be
ah will be diagonal because
a j with respect to del
z i is equal to 0 if i is not equal to j
and ordinarily if it was not a
element then the first column of that
matrix will
just be
right exactly so uh so so if this was
not an element wise operation then here
we would have
you know d a
1 by d z 1 d
1 d a 2 by d z
1 and so on until d
a whatever m by or
n by d z n and so on so you you take
every possible partial
derivative of the output with respect to
the input and and that's your jacobian
here
and here just because we are doing an
element-wise operation all these are
zeros
right so
yeah so this would be you know if it is
m by n then this would be
a yeah d a1 by dzn yeah you're right so
yeah the
basically the the the m cross n of all
the partials right
so what we observe is that in this chain
of jacobians
every other jacobian is going to be a
diagonal matrix
because its an element wise operation
happening every other step
and so this
is a diagonal matrix
of g prime
and now what what what about
del z say ah
l over del a
l minus one so by
by z l to a l minus one we are asking
you know zl to a minus 1 how do we go
how do we get z l from a l minus 1 we do
w w a plus w a plus b
so here
so z l was
w l times
a l minus 1
plus b l
so ah z l by a l minus 1
if you do it element wise you will see
that this this
turns out to be exactly just l
why is that ah take the ith element of
z and the ith element of z
so z i equals
sum over j w i j
aj so the partial element
the partial derivative of z i with
respect to aj is w i j
which means the partial of of this
entire jacobian is just the w matrix
so this so this is a matrix
multiplication so here i'm seeing this
matrix multiplication for just one
element
so the plus b is is going to cancel
because we're taking with respect to a
right so yeah there is a plus b and you
know when you're taking the
derivative of this with respect to a you
know b is b is just
uh yeah sure sure sure yeah all right
thanks
right so what we saw so the initial part
is
a linear model followed by
diagonal jacobian followed by
a jacobian which is the l minus 1
layer times a diagonal
g prime times w l minus 2
and so on right so this
long you know
multivariate chain rule chain has
this has this pattern of starting off
with a linear model followed by
alternating between a diagonal matrix on
the w matrix diagonal matrix and the w
matrix
until we reach until we reach
the z layer of until the z vector of the
corresponding layer
right and what happens here
partial of let us call it z 2
with respect to w
i j of 2. so this is the
the last part
so here we make the observation right we
start from here again
we
del so the partial of z2 with respect to
w
i j we see that w
i j only interacts with a j
so this actually is is so after making
this observation make this other
observation that
the numerator here is a vector and the
denominator is a
scalar so this jacobian
is a column matrix
right output is vector
input scalar so the rows is a vector
input is a scalar
and we also observe that the role played
by w
i j only impacts
z i so w i j has no effect on
any other any other z
so what does this mean so ah it's easy
so z equals
w times a
so w i j so you you can think of
the i element of z as the dot product
between the ith row of w
and the a column vector right and
this is equal to the dot product of this
times a
so any w i j any cell
can only impact the z i element of
the ith element of z it has no no impact
on
any other element of z right so
this
this jacobian will have zeros everywhere
except the
ith ith element and this
ith element is going to be aj
aj
so um w i j is the uh
uh is the parameter with respect to
which we are
taking the the derivative so z i
is w wij times aj so aj comes here
and for every other z k
you know w i j has no role in it so
it's going to be zeros everywhere except
aj at the ith position
does this make sense right so
this this ah vector over here
is a column vector
with a j in the ith position
and zeros everywhere
now what does this mean so we have a row
vector over here
and a column vector over here
right now if we take the dot product
between this row vector and this column
vector we we get the answer that we are
looking for
we also observed that the column vector
has
only one non-zero element and everything
else was zeros
right and when you take the dot product
between such
a column vector and this row vector
because most of them are zeros
and only the ith element over here is
non-zero
this dot product will be the ith element
of this row vector times a j
that makes sense so
we have some vector
times 0 everywhere
aj at the ith position 0.
so this dot product is you know let me
call this
b 1 through say b b k
so this the the dot product of these two
will be just b
i a j
is this clear
so partial of l with respect to w i j
is the i-th element of this row vector
times
a j so let me write that here
so this whole thing let me call it ah
say
del of two
dot product with
product with zero
a j zero
and del two was basically
partial of loss with respect to
z 2 times
0 a j
and this is
partial of l with respect to
z 2. so this was a row vector there is a
column vector
this row vectors
ith element times aj
so this is the derivative that we are
interested in calculating
right what we saw was because of the
chain rule
it was this row vector
times this column vector where this
column vector was mostly zeros except
you know the i term
uh the calculation of going from here to
here or this entire thing
oh just this one okay so the the
derivative of
z with respect to w i j right so z
what we saw
the z vector is w matrix times
a column right so the the derivative of
z with respect to w i j some i throw
and j i j
element of w will be because it's just a
matrix multiplication
w i j can only impact the ith row of z
yeah so only the ith element of this
of this gradient vector will will be
non-zero
everything else is zero yeah exactly
but just following the formula
[Music]
so if you expand that out it's going to
be like w1 wi
a1 wi-1 i don't know how you can write
it out but
basically the derivatives you still have
only i term is that what you're saying
yeah yeah so w i um
so if you take the derivative of this
with respect to w i j
right so only aj will remain
yeah so that's aj that's why aj comes
here and everything else is zeros
so um
so the the partial of l with respect to
w i j is this
long row vector times this special
column vector that has only a j in the
ith element and this is you know
when you take the dot product because
this is the ith element
we get the ith element of this row
vector times aj
right so aj was a scalar in this vector
now it is just a scalar
now what does what is what does this
pattern tell us if del
l with respect to w
two is now therefore just the outer
product between this
and this so this is going to be
del
z2
times
i guess i should have been putting a
superscript of 2 everywhere
a2 transpose
right so this from here to here is just
you know
linear algebra notation
is this clear
let me explain this part again
the partial of l with respect to w i j
was this row vector times this column
vector
that we got from here this row vector
times this column vector
but this column vector happens to be a
special column vector that has only the
ith element to be non-zero
which is why we can we can ah we can
write this dot product as the ith
element
of this vector times a j
and because now uh
this i j th element of this matrix is
the ith element of this vector times the
j-th element of this vector
then the the full matrix is basically
the outer product
this question
yeah so this so this is with respect to
w2
yeah so this is probably yeah this is
with respect to one thanks yeah
and this is also if you want
anyways the the ah the main idea here is
how we went from this
special column vector having just one
nonzero element
into this notation and from this
notation
[Music]
we when we extend this into the full
matrix
you know this just becomes the outer
product
all right so once we are able to
calculate the derivatives of the loss
with respect to
all the weight matrices we can do
something exactly similar to the bias
terms to the b
vectors we repeat this for every layer
we we get the collection of all the
derivatives of the loss with respect to
the corresponding matrices
and we take a gradient descent step in
the
direction of negative of this
so what we get is w
l equals colon equals
w l minus alpha times
partial of l over
partial of w l
where the partial of l with respect to
partial wl was calculated as this
outer product at the end
there are a lot of moving parts but it's
it's basically just
you know multivariate calculus a chain
rule applied in a mechanical fashion
there are a lot of moving parts but
you know it's just chain rule and
calculus
yes question
you start
yeah so i guess the question is uh you
know
is there a preferred order in which we
perform this with respect to the
different l layers
the the uh the way we generally do it is
first we calculate the l uh the partial
l with respect to wl for
every layer and in order to do that in
order to reuse computation you want to
start with the last layer first
and then work your way backwards because
you're using lots of computation
and then once you have the full
collection of your partials
these can be done in parallel because
once you have this this
this matrix you know you're only
updating the health layers parameters
using this matrix and so this update can
be done in parallel for all the layers
but to calculate the updates itself you
you want to do it serially
starting from the final layer and
working your way backwards
because you can reuse a lot of the
intermediate computations
exactly so uh we we're going to reuse
we're going to reuse of in order to
calculate uh del l
by w i j 1 we're going to reuse
everything until z2
and get a few more and two more
jacobians
and calculate specific calculate the
branch specific to the first layer
so because we are reusing a lot of these
intermediate values you want to start at
the end and work your way backwards and
that's why it's called back propagation
so what i meant by calculate two more
jacobians is in order to calculate
w two i j we would have calculated
everything until z two
and now in order to calculate with
respect to w one i j
we reuse everything we did until here
and get two more jacobians
and
the first the first one will be uh what
do you mean by first one will subtle z1
after the the two jacobians are a1 to
one ah the the the two chakrins are z
two to a one and a one to z one
and then the branch will be z one
exactly and the branch will be
z one to w i j exactly
yeah the same with respect to b the the
the uh
in fact b is a little simpler than what
we did for w w is the harder case which
is why we work through it b
is is going to be very simple you know
what is the the
partial of z with respect to b 1 partial
of z with respect to b 2
you know and work it out it in fact is
going to be much simpler than w
right so again for b in order to
calculate for b
2 i everything until z 2 from the loss
is the same
and you just have a different branch
right so any any any any uh
immediate questions with respect to back
propagation
yes
so the question is we start with the
input layer which is of dimension d
and this is like you know your d
dimensional input if it's like prices
you know if you're
you're um like if you're trying to do
some kind of a
say a linear regression then these are
the features of your x's
one example this is one example that's
why i write x superscript i so this is
one example
yeah so i'm coming to the multiple
examples next so all of this was
we've seen it with respect to one
example
right now what do we do when there are
multiple examples
i'll uh before before i jump on to that
i want to make sure
there are no outstanding questions on on
back propagation right
uh it is fine if you haven't understood
all the details right now
i would recommend you to you know go
back and work through the notes and work
out these
parts yourselves the and while you're
working out through the math
step by step the key steps the key
points to have in mind
is to break down the big problem into
this
into this smaller steps where you know
there are these two steps a to z and z
to a that repeat over and over
and the jacobians of those are very
simple so
z to a is a diagonal jacobian and
a to z is just the w matrix so this will
always be just the w matrix and this
will always be
diagonal of g prime
now a to z is the w matrix z to a is g
prime jacobians
because you went through g so the
derivative of a with respect to c will
just be the diagonal of g
right yeah so
yeah a to z will be always a diagonal
matrix z to a will always be just the w
matrix
right and this you can you know repeat
it depending on
how many layers you have and once you
reach the final layer
this part is just like logistic
regression or any glm in general
so glm diagonal w diagonal w diagonal w
and then you have something that's
specific to the branch
and the part that's specific to the
branch is
this this a special column vector that
has
only a j at the ith position for for
w i j right and you take the row vector
and
take the column vector you get you
evaluate it you you get the value for
del l uh the derivative of l with
respect to w i j
and then you observe that this is just
the i th element of one vector times the
j th element of the other vector
and so the derivative with respect to
the matrix is just the outer product
between these two
right there are a lot of moving parts
but you know pretty much straightforward
so should there be a transpose where
over here
so this is you know the
ah i am not sure understood
yeah this is a matrix yes
oh so this should be yeah so so yeah so
think of
so dl by z2 in our case
was a row vector so yes so you can you
can have
but but uh the idea here is the outer
product between two vectors think of it
as the outer product between these
two vectors whether they're row or
column you know calculate the outer
product
element of your jth element of a that
becomes the ijth element of the matrix
right ok
so this was with respect to one example
when we have the way we generally train
these neural networks
in practice is with gradient descent
but we do not always do stochastic
gradient design
what we do is something that is called
as mini batch gradient design
and in mini batch gradient descent it is
similar to stochastic gradient descent
where except
instead of sampling one example at
random we sample a batch of examples at
random
right so in
in practice to train we define j
of w's and b's
where this is the set of all w's across
all layers and set of all b's across all
layers
right and we define this as the sum
from i equals 1 to capital b
loss of y i
y at i
right so where b
is size of
mini batch
right so when we when we
ah when we are now working with
so so far we we consider x to be a
vector
but if you are working with a mini batch
let see what happens
let us see what happens in the first
layer so in the first layer we have
zi z1 was equal to
w1 times
x i plus
b one right so this was
ah
let us call it m by m
ah so m by d if
assuming the first the output of the
first layer has dimension
m x because its the input has d
dimension
and b also therefore has
m and z
is also a vector of size m so
and this of dimension d
right so w times x
will give us a vector of size
m right
and this is a vector of size m and
output is a vector of size m
right and this was all fine when we were
let's put a cross one to just
this was all fine with respect to one
example now what happens when
in place of x i we take a mini batch of
x's
so what happens if we do
w of 1 which is still
m by d and in place of x
we have a mini batch of x
1 x 2
x b so this is now
d by capital b
right plus
b one and this is still m by one
so this this matrix multiplication will
give us something that is
m by b
but now we are trying to add
something of dimension m by 1
to an entity of dimension m by b
right but this does not work you cannot
add
2 to a vector and a matrix
or 2 matrices or two vectors whose
dimensions don't match exactly
right and over here
what is most of the
most of the softwares that you use for
training machine learning uh especially
neural networks you know like tensorflow
pytorch
numpy all these software applications
deal with such a scenario of adding
an m by one to m by b by something
called broadcasting
right so when you are implementing your
you know neural network in your homework
which is there in your
homework too you might wonder how
you're going to take this m by b
dimension and add a
b and add an m dimension vector to it
and as long as your as long as your
dimensions uh match up in this way where
you have
m on the left and b and one on the right
most of the computer software including
numpy will perform something called
broadcasting which means it's going to
make
which is it is going to broadcast this m
by 1
vector into an m by
b vector by making multiple virtual
copies of itself
as multiple columns next question
is it equivalent
so the question is is this would it be
equivalent to
multiplying b by
by what a row vector of ones
so b by one times one by
one by b ah filled with ones
uh yes exactly so you can you can uh do
it explicitly
and make multiple copies of your b and
that will consume more memory
in your computer uh whereas um you know
broadcasting is this
you know uh you you're probably going to
come across you know broadcasting errors
when you're doing homework you know when
you know things are not
you know all right um so broadcasting is
this feature
in in most computer software which which
work on matrices where it it
makes multiple virtual copies of this
vector to match up the dimensions
and that's something you just need to be
aware of
it is mathematically it is equivalent to
multiplying
a a row vector of ones and making
multiple copies yes
mathematically it's equivalent but
actually performing this
is very algorithmically expensive you're
going to use a lot of memory use a lot
of computation
broadcasting is a feature that you know
the software's implement to
do it virtually for you
this question
yeah so the good question so in the
other
um other uh algorithms we use stochastic
gradient descent and
um and because of problems for convex we
kind of you know knew that it would
go to the the global minimum or nearby
the global minimum
but neural networks are not convex um
and what's
and and um the stochastic gradient
doesn't make sense
in neural networks i guess is a very
good valid question right and the
answer there is it is
valid the the
if you look at the theory of using
stochastic gradient methods
um so there are there are certain
conditions
so again you know this is for your
reference so
the the the if you want to go deeper
into this look up stochastic
approximation
approximation and one of the very first
papers that introduced this idea was
from a pair of authors i think it was
robinson monroe
robbins and
munro so ah when they introduced
this whole idea of stochastic uh
stochastic optimization of stochastic
gradient descent uh it was
introduced in the context of stochastic
approximations and
what the theory says is if you perform
this gradient descend
with your learning rate you know we used
in in all our methods we use
a constant learning rate alpha
but if uh in this paper they give a
proof that
as long as your learning rate is also
decreasing over time
and if it is decreasing at a rate such
that
so supposing if alpha one is the
learning rate used at
time step one or or the step size one
as long as you as long as you decay your
learning rate over time such that
some more time alpha t
is infinity
but sum over t alpha t
square is less than infinity which means
the sum of the learning rate values
explodes to infinity but the sum of the
squares of the learning rates you know
converges
as long as your learning rate follows
this condition
then stochastic gradient descent will
converge
to some local optima right
and that local optima in case of neural
networks could be any local optima
right gradient descent will will also
take you to some local optima
in a neural network but we don't know
what it is anyways
and you know then you know why the extra
concern when you start using stochastic
gradient descent is you know uh is is a
response
and in terms of when exactly stochastic
gradient descent
will converge to a local minima as long
as your
learning rate follows these set of
conditions stochastic gradient descent
will converge to a local minima even if
the problem is non-convexity take you to
a local minimum
right in practice we don't
follow learning rates in this
that meet this condition but
it is actually common to anneal your
learning rate in some way
um may not be in this way but it's it's
common to decrease your learning rate
in neural networks uh it's a commonly
done practice though not in the in that
fashion so sdd will take you to a local
optima um
but uh you know you have no guarantees
just the way you have no guarantees with
gradient descent itself
so the question is um you know the the
these models are very expensive to
compute uh you know calculating all this
back propagation so
why do we do mini batch instead of just
stochastic um you
so the the uh the reason why you want to
do mini batches because most of these
softwares are
implemented on gpus where you get
parallelism for free kind of so if
you're not doing
you know at least some amount of
parallelism you're kind of leaving money
on the table
so you want to use you know make use of
the parallelism somehow
and also when you when you move from
stochastic gradient descent to mini
batch gradient descent
the noise in your gradient direction
comes down significantly
so if you're averaging across multiple
examples you know the
noisiness in in in each step that you
take
is uh reduces significantly this
question
um
why should that have anything to do with
whether
so i'm not going to go into the details
of this i'm happy to go into you know
more details of this after the lecture
if you're interested in i would highly
recommend you know reading up this paper
it gives you all the details of
you know what are the necessary
conditions um
probably there's also a sufficient
condition for your training process
exactly yes yes so the papers are uh the
the idea here is
any set of learning rates you take no
matter what your loss function is
if they follow these these conditions
then you will converge to a local optima
exactly
well not all the alphas some of the
initial alphas could be very big
but you know but the sum of the square
of the alpha should converge to some
finite value
all right ah a few more comments about
neural networks before we move on
so one view of neural network
is to start with this picture
and you know remember we we first
consider the last layer as a linear
model
and everything else is something else
this
view basically tells you that what a
neural network is doing
is transforming your xs
into some phi of x
right so you can think of this whole
network this whole thing
to be some fee of
x where the fees are parameterized by w
and b
right think of it as a feature map right
we we came up with some
hard coded features and problem set one
in the last question like you know
polynomials and you know sinusoidal
features etcetera
but essentially what this neural network
is doing is taking your input
and transforming it to some other space
and then you
apply your glm or any linear model
that we were that we've seen before so
neural networks
in a way are a way to learn
representations so everything that
happened from x
until a of l minus 1 was learning a way
to represent x
so that the glm could consume that
representation
right so that is one view of neural
networks where your neural network
is some learnable feature map
plus linear model
right in in case of linear models we
would only learn the parameters
over here but in the case of neural
networks we are jointly learning
the parameter of the linear model and
the parameters of the feature map
yes question everything everything
simultaneously exactly when we do
gradient gradient ascent or gradient
descent
we are updating the parameters of the
last layer and
the initial layers all at the same time
so in a way you're
you're trying to learn what the right
parameters of the linear model needs to
be
and also at the same time learning
what are good representations that are
going to help my linear model
right so linear in fact one of the
leading
conferences of deep learning is called
iclr
you know it's it's a academic conference
that's kind of dedicated to deep
learning
and the name of iclr stands for
international conference of learning
representations
right so that's what deep learning is
doing it is learning
representations so that you can apply
linear models that you're already
familiar with
which which which gives some interesting
additional perspectives that is once you
have a feature map
i guess what i'm what i'm about to say
you know beyond this point about neural
networks
are um are not some things we're going
to ask you in your exam but are you know
good to know especially if you want to
get into machine learning research
associated with every neural network is
a kernel a kernel which given two
examples i
x i x j is the
phi of x i transpose
v of x j where the phi r
is the thing that takes it from x to
here right so every neural network kind
of comes
with an implicit kernel where the kernel
is represented by this
explicit feature map right which means
now
this gives you a way in which you can
use neural networks
with gaussian processes right in
gaussian processes you needed a kernel
to to tell you how similar or dissimilar
to examples were right and over there
you can use neural networks
you can you can there are ways in which
you can learn kernels which means you
can learn
these neural networks for the for for
that gp process and
and you know that's that's a very
elegant way of combining gaussian
processes and neural networks where a
neural network becomes
the kernel of your gp there are also a
few other
interesting
few other interesting results with
neural networks
so there is another
interesting i guess
linked to gaussian processes where
there is another paper which which shows
that a single layer neural network
which means one hidden layer and one
output layer
where the input are your axes and you
have one hidden layer and one output
layer
as the number of
neurons in the hidden layer tend to
infinity then the neural network
becomes a gaussian process itself which
is another interesting link between
caution processes and neural networks
if you are interested in those paper you
know make a post on pr's and happy to
shared links to those papers however
ah the the other um interesting
uh interesting
idea of neural networks is this thing
called the universal approximation
theorem
again these you know we are not going to
ask you about these in your
exams or homework or anything but these
are good to know you know
especially if you want to get into
machine learning research so the
universal approximation theorem says
if you have a function say
y equals f of x where
x you know assume its from r d
and y is in you know some r
let us call it k right and you are
interested in some bounded
region of x
which means say if your x's are for
example some some
image right then you are only interested
in
the region of x where the pixel value is
between some range right that's that
that kind of
limits our region of interest of the
inputs so given a bounded region of
interest then there exists
exists a neural network
of one hidden layer
which means your input layer
is x in rd
your final is y
in rk
and you have a hidden layer a fully
connected hidden layer
right and the universal approximation
theorem says
if you have a function
with a given region of interest of your
inputs
then for any smooth any continuous f
any a function f that is continuous
there exists a neural network with a
finite number of hidden layers
that can approximate f to an arbitrary
degree of precision
right and and that could be surprising
ah initially so any f that is continuous
if you define a region of interest in
the input space of x
no matter what no matter what f you have
there exists a neural network with a
single hidden layer
with a finite number of hidden
dimensions
but that number of dimensions can be
exponentially large
but it's still finite and
that neural network can approximate
y to an arbitrary degree of precision
so if you come up with a degree of
tolerance epsilon say call it you know
10 to the minus 6 then you can construct
a neural network
f hat of x such that f hat of x
minus f of x is less than epsilon for
all values of
x in the bounded region this question so
i guess i wouldn't call it a violation
of no free lunch because gaussian
processes could also do this you know it
can
approximate anything if you have a non
parametric thing but here
ah the results as you know in a in a a
parametric setting
this can this can
this can basically mimic f to an
arbitrary degree of precision
right you you throw in more input layers
then your degree of precision improves
but
ah yes question sorry on the right hand
side
no no it's just this you know consider
the the output
over here no nonlinear so that's already
the prediction
yeah if you think of that you know you
you can you can you can construct a
network like this
where um um so if if you think of your y
as a scalar value then i guess you know
you would just have one cell over here
why bother with more than one
so so yeah i'm coming to that so right
so
it tells you the universal approximation
tells you that any function
continuous function f can be
approximated to any arbitrary degree of
precision with a one layer neural
network
as long as you're willing to you know
have
lots of hidden hidden units however
um so so that that's basically you know
theoretically a mathematically you know
true valid result
and and you know that's probably you
know a big reason why there's a lot of
interest in neural networks because it
has
you know such good expressivity power
however the catch that comes with this
is
it does not tell you that it does not
tell you or give you a recipe
of how to recover that function or how
to recover that configuration
you know it does not tell you that with
gradient descent you can you can reach
that
configuration of the network right
and it also ah doesn't tell you
how many samples of x and y pairs you
need to mimic it you know
there are lots of lots of
catches that come with it but it it's
still a valid mathematical result that
by adjusting your parameters in some way
it doesn't tell you how but
a configuration exists where it mimics
any continuous function f
to an arbitrary degree of precision next
question
uh i don't remember the details but you
know
it's it's it's uh it's not a very uh i
don't think
it needs to be lip lip sheets
it probably needs to be i i don't
remember but you know it's it's it's
um for most practical purposes all the
kind of functions that you may want to
learn are
are are covered under that next question
yeah i guess you know this is just a
mathematical result which which tells
you that
there's a way in which you can adjust
the weights and biases of your network
to mimic f of x
to an arbitrary degree of precision um
you know that's just a mathematical
result and you probably want to view it
outside the context of
you know your data and test set and
whatnot
but you know um that's still that's
still a valid result and
that's basically you know ah kind of
spurred a lot of interest in neural
networks because hey they are you know
universal
function approximators and as long as i
have a good enough data set
that you know that that's kind of
representative of you know your
uh your function and maybe gradient
descent will get us there you know but
there's no proof that
gradient descent will get you there but
you know maybe it does
there's no algorithm of how to extract
such effect all it tells you is that
there exists an effect
so we can just make predictions using
that
again i would i would not think of it in
the context of
of a prediction versus learning versus
inference
um it all it's telling you is there
exists some configuration doesn't tell
you how to reach that configuration
right so so now you know uh neural
networks are therefore in theory you
know the
the hypothesis class of neural networks
if you're able to
if you know afford a pretty large
intermediate
uh hidden layers the hypothesis class is
pretty big
you can approximate any function uh you
can you can
you know or continuous function you can
think of you know in in some
bounded region of input
and and which which kind of ah
forms a nice segue to our next set of
topics of you know bias variance
tradeoff
i don't think we have time to finish it
today we're going to pick it up again on
on on friday but maybe just you know
lay out the setting so that we can we
can pick it up from uh friday
questions
good question so um so the question is
we use neural networks to come up with
non-linear hypotheses
and a decade ago or so svms you know
with kernels
could also do non-linear decision
boundaries
and why is the recent you know trend or
shift in interest towards neural
networks and away from
svms i guess um
few few possible reasons
or likely reasons one is svms require
you to handcraft a kernel
it's you know you need to use your
intuition to come up with
um you know a good mathematical kernel
for it um
for it to work well the second is uh
whereas in neural networks the feature
map is kind of learned from data
right you don't have to construct a
mathematically valid kernel
you know the data and gradient descent
will kind of figure out
a reasonable implicit kernel in this
case the other reason is because
neural networks are very computational
intensive
right they are extremely computationally
intensive especially as you add more
uh deeper layers and they are also very
sample inefficient so by sample
inefficiency
what i mean is you need a lot of data
for the neural network to work well
right whereas other algorithms are a lot
more sample efficient they kind of work
at their
maximum capacity with a lot fewer um
data sets
and recently the trend in computing is
that a lot of data is now digitized like
pictures or you know images are you know
you get a lot of uh images which are
digitized now and also there's
a huge jump in computation with gpus and
stuff right so
the two obstacles that were kind of
holding back neural networks
you know lots of computation and lots of
data
are kind of now met um
another um in terms of algorithmically
there hasn't been a lot of
or there hasn't been a whole lot of
fundamental changes to neural network
algorithmically except probably the
the introduction of the activation
function called the value
which we saw the other day you know
which is equal to
max of 0 comma x
right so relu addressed
one i would say a problem with neural
networks
by of making it very deep which was
uh something that's called the vanishing
gradient
we probably won't be covering vanishing
gradients but the idea there is
if you have an activation function that
looks like this and
if your activation function the input
your activation function is some
you know z value here then the a value
will be whatever one
but the the derivative of over there is
pretty much zero
so the jacobian will just be you know it
has zeros everywhere else but you know
these
elements will also be end up being zeros
so you take
the the the gradient of of the next
layer multiplied by as
uh jacobian at zero then you know
everything behind
are are pretty much going to get zero um
gradients
so this this um
this problem was kind of solved with
values and it's it's kind of a you know
if you look at this kind of hacky right
it's just
but you know in practice it works it
works pretty well and and
so the the you know trend in increasing
in
you know computation power and increase
in data and with
very few algorithmic improvements like
this you know
is is probably why there's
interest in deep learning
yeah so the question is you know uh
there is a kernel that we
you know um that we showed that uh every
neural network kind of implicitly
defines a kernel
you know that's associated with its
feature map and svms use kernels so
what's
why you know is there a reason to use
svms
again and the answer is actually very
few people use
svms except
there are still probably a few cases
where you don't have a lot of data
you know that's kind of one regime where
neural networks don't work well if you
don't have a lot of data
and other you know others you know more
more simpler methods are still
commonly used ah another uh interesting
thing
that might be interesting is you can
train a neural network
with with you know in this way and
just use it as a feature extractor to
map
your your examples to some higher level
feature space
and then you can feed that into other
algorithms you know that's
that's something that people do as well
so train a network on your full training
set
right and learn this feature map and
then on other exam
you know um on on the same examples you
know kind of chop off your network at
this stage
extract the features that the network
learn and then say
train um you know like a random forest
or some some other algorithm
on this representation of your inputs
and that's that's people do that
sometimes as well
is there another question
yes so
doesn't it have a bigger
vanishing gradient problem because
everything on the left
like everything that's less than zero
like at least the sigmoid
yeah so the question is in relu won't
you have vanishing gradient problems
here
uh the answer is the answer is uh yes
over here the
gradients do vanish however the
input that goes into activation is
actually the output of some linear
transformation
right which means it's going to be
different for different values of x
so yes
uh over here the one the gradient is is
um
is zero and that is a problem of value
and people have come up with
kind of again hacky fixes for it they
call it leaky value where
leaky value is you know it's like this
until zero and then it has a much
smaller gradient over here right so
you know it's like instead of being
exactly zero everything
it has a small negative slope so there
are fixes
or you know ways around it but in
practice value seems to
work why would you do something
there are infinitely many
non-linearities
that seem so crazy i mean it's it's
easy to compute so it's inexpensive to
compute
this question is there a universal
approximation
i'm not familiar with the universal
approximation theorem for svms
literally any theoretically any any
possible
mapping you can have from x to y
it's continuous and you're interested in
some bounded region of input
can actually space that mapping that
feature map
but i mean like you can't uh yeah you
want to learn those w's and b's which
have the correct feature map
uh why can you elaborate more on that
what does that mean
why can't you do that so all i said was
the
approximation theorem doesn't offer you
a recipe of how to recover that network
it just tells it's an existence theorem
it says you know
that such a network exists that's all
the theorem says
and why would it not be so you're saying
the only problem
uh with actually achieving that some
ideal
optimal configuration
is that
so there are many challenges in order to
even get it right so
how many samples of x and y pairs do you
need you know that right there you have
like an obstacle if you want to you
train it with gradient design
right anyways so that's that's um
that's fine so the the main the main
idea that you want to take away from
this
is that neural networks are extremely
expressive
the set of all hypotheses that a neural
network can represent
can be extremely large right a linear
linear regression was limited to just
straight lines
right but neural networks are in a way
you know much much much bigger
and which which kind of you know um
[Music]
will lead us to the next topic of bias
variance tradeoff of you know
is this always a good idea you know is
is more expressivity
always a desired thing and we'll we'll
jump into
uh bias variance trade-offs on on
on friday and to just wrap up today's
lecture
uh i would i would kind of stress upon
the idea of back propagation you know
think about it in terms of
this daisy chain of jacobians where each
of the jacobians are pretty easy to
compute it's either a diagonal matrix or
just the w itself the end of the neural
network
we've seen it before they're just linear
models we've seen glms
and and the gradient over here follows
just like a linear model and then you
have a daisy chain of jacobians
and the branches to each of the w's and
b's are again very simple math
the notation may be a little confusing
because you have these zero
vectors full of zeros with only some uh
elements non zeros and
you kind of view them as outer products
etc but that's again
straightforward linear algebra work
through it you know
ones from the notes and hopefully that
should be clear if not you know post on
piazza
right we'll stop today thanks